food is fundamental to life but today
our eating habits go far beyond simple
nutritional needs obesity now surpasses
hunger as the world's leading food and
nutrition problem here in the United
States obesity and the issues
surrounding it have reached epidemic
proportions more than half of adults and
one third of all children are already
overweight or obese when you really look
over the last three decades to try to
see how body weight has changed what you
see is that things are really quite
steady for a very long time and then
through the 80s and 90s you just see
this rapid increase in the prevalence of
obesity across the country researchers
now believe the sudden rise in American
obesity is due to a rapid shift in the
way we eat our food environment has
changed drastically but our human
biology has not how we respond to the
environment
is largely a function of our
evolutionary history we tend to think of
our bodies of being static for evolution
to occur hundreds thousands millions of
years needs to pass what we're finding
here is that if you tweak something very
important to our biology such as the
amount of food or how much we move about
it can have a dramatic effect within a
really short period of time what's
really changed in terms of our forager
past versus what we are today has to do
with the fact that our activities gone
down tremendously we can now get food
with virtually no work so you can pick
up the phone and order a pizza and get a
huge number of calories after expending
virtually no calories at all of course
what we are eating has an impact as well
we get high sugar high salt high fat
food
foods it overrides our ability to
self-regulate it keeps signaling to our
brain keep eating keep eating now's your
chance to get a lot of calories and it's
very hard for people to realize when
they're full from 1984 to 1994 Americans
collectively gained more than a billion
pounds gaining access to healthy food is
not always easy
today more than 13 million Americans
live in what are now called food deserts
cities and towns that have little or no
access to stores selling healthy foods
we remain concerned about the food
desert that is the access to healthy
foods that are really affordable for
people we've also become aware that the
food swamp really impacts what we eat
and therefore our weight and our health
a food swamp is Yerevan neighborhood
that's full of fast food restaurants and
corner stores selling mostly high fat
and high sugar food and beverages over
the past three decades the popularity
and easy availability of inexpensive
processed and fast food has severely
limited healthy choices in our food
environment this change has also
contributed to a startling increase in
the average portion of food consumed a
some combination of consumer demand and
the marketplace has decided to give us
bigger portions with the idea that we're
getting more value when we think about
portion size we're so biased to think
about that super-sized meal when in fact
the average portion of meat or fish
should be no bigger than a deck of cards
regard to beverages when we think about
consumption across the nation we are
drinking twice as much soda as milk soft
drinks were always around but people
tended to have a small portion as the
amount of soft drinks available
increased you saw not just the portion
size increase but you also saw machines
being put into all kinds of new places
like schools
all of this affects our well-being and
the well-being of future generations the
impact of obesity is tremendous on the
healthcare system for most it has a
large impact on many many chronic
diseases that we see in adulthood and
many of the diseases that cost the most
in terms of treatment and
hospitalization overall it accounts for
close to a third of all healthcare costs
that are incurred in the United States
we now know the causes of the obesity
epidemic are complex but solutions are
being found all around us small changes
can make a big impact we can make
changes for ourselves individually for
our families and also in our community
common ground is a charter school in New
Haven Connecticut that focuses on
environmental education with a working
organic farm in an urban setting common
ground aims to teach students and the
community about healthy eating and urban
sustainability we have several classes
that focus on food and agriculture where
we get our students to think about what
the impacts of their food choices are
both the environmental impacts the
health impacts and sort of the social
impacts of the choices they make regard
to food
my first year here I actually brought
coca-cola and different prostitutes with
me to school for lunch every day now I
rarely even have soda I avoid processed
foods as much as possible I try to play
persuade my mom to buy you know organic
food organic vegetable organic
everything you know it's a better our
life and hers because I want to see my
family you know grow strong and healthy
it's important to us not just to get our
food make our food accessible but to
really work on a statewide and regional
ID level to try and fix a broken food
system that makes it very difficult to
access locally grown healthy foods
community programs like common ground
are starting to make an impact on the
way people think about their food
choices with a growing understanding of
what is led to the obesity epidemic we
can now make educated decisions on how
to best address the problem and how to
make healthier choices for future
generations
you
you